COMMITTEE IS CALLED TO ORDER
GOOD AFTERNOON AND WELCOME BACK
TO THE ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE. THE ON. DUTY DUE THE
ONGOING COVERT NINETEEN
RESTRICTIONS WE ARE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCING IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITAL SO WE'RE ONLY ABLE TO
HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WATCH OR PARTICIPATE IN THE
HEARING IN PERSON. MASUR
REQUIRED FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS IN
THE HEARING ROOM IN THE WITNESS
VIDEO CONFERENCING ROOM IN ROOM
ONE TWENTY FIVE OF THE CAPITAL
AND AT THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION ON THE CAPITOL GROUNDS.
YOU CAN TESTIFY IN PERSON IN
THE HEARING ROOM AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION OR USING OUR
TELEPHONE SERVICE. THE NUMBER
TO CALL IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS CODE IS.
TWO FOUR TWO SIX TWO THREE
SEVEN. FOR EACH BILL BEING
DISCUSSED TODAY THERE WILL BE
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR TWO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND IN
OPPOSITION. TO EACH PROVIDE TWO
MINUTES OF COMMENTARY. THAT'S
TWO WITNESSES ON EACH SIDE FOR
TWO MINUTES EACH. FOR
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES CALLING
INTO THE PHONE LINE WILL BE
PLACED IN QUEUE UNTIL YOUR
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE. PUBLIC
COMMENT PLEASE MUTE YOUR DEVICE
TO REDUCE SOUND DISTORTIONS.
AND FOR THE PUBLIC TO CALLS ON
THAT LINE YOU'LL BE LIMITED TO
ONE MINUTE OR LESS AND YOU'LL
BE ASKED TO PROVIDE YOUR NAME
ANY ORGANIZATION AND JUST
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
EACH BILL. I SUPPORTED
OPPOSITION WILL BE BLENDED ON
THE PHONE LINE PLEASE BE VERY
BRIEF AGAIN AND LIMIT YOUR
COMMENTS TO YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION IF.
YOU START TO GO LONGER THAN
THAT WE WILL HAVE TO CUT YOU
OFF DUE TO TIME CONSTRAINTS. IF
YOU'RE HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH
THE MODERATED PHONE SERVICE YOU
CAN CALL THE COMMITTEE DIRECTLY
AT NINE ONE SIX. THREE ONE NINE
TWO ZERO NINE THREE AND MY
STAFF WILL TRY TO HELP YOU.
FINALLY I ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC
TO PROVIDE WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. BEFORE WE GET STARTED
I WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
RECOGNIZE FORMER SENATE PRO TEM
GAINES MILLS WHO PASSED AWAY ON
MARCH TWENTY SEVENTH AT THE AGE
OF NINETY THREE. PROTERRA MILLS
WITH WAS A CHAMPION OF PUBLIC
TRANSIT WHICH IS WHY WE ARE
MENTIONING HIM HERE TODAY. HE
WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR THE TRANSIT
DEVELOPMENT ACT WHICH IS THE
MAIN LOCAL FUNDING SOURCE OF
PUBLIC TRANSIT ACROSS THE STATE.
HE AUTHORED LEGISLATION
CREATING THE METROPOLITAN
TRANSIT DEVELOPMENT BOARD.
RESPONSIBLE FOR CREATING THE
TROLLEY LIGHT RAIL SYSTEM IN
SAN DIEGO. THAT HAS BECOME THE
BLUEPRINT FOR LIGHT RAIL ACROSS
THE US. AFTER TWENTY TWO YEARS
OF SERVICE IN THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE HE WENT ON TO CHAIR
THE METROPOLITAN TRANSIT
DEVELOPMENT BOARD SERVED ON THE
AMTRAK BOARD AND MOST RECENTLY
SERVED ON THE CALIFORNIA HIGH
SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY. HE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS TWO DAUGHTERS
SON AND NINE GRANDCHILDREN. HIS
FAMILY HAS ASKED PEOPLE TO TAKE
A RIDE ON THE TROLLEY A TRAIN
OR ON A BIKE IN HIS MEMORY.
WITH THAT WE WILL BEGIN OUR
HEARING SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. FRIEDMAN HERE FALL
HERE BERMAN. CUNNINGHAM DALY.%
DAVIES GIPSON- KALRA. WE MEDINA.
NAZARIAN WHEN. O'DONNELL WARD.
WICKS. DO WE HAVE A QUORUM YET.
YES OKAY WE DO HAVE A FARM DO I
HAVE A MOTION FOR THE CONSENT
FILE. HEY WE HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. FRIEDMAN YES FONG.
BERMAN CUNNINGHAM. DALY DAVIES.
GIPSON OUR KALRA. WE ARE MEDINA.
THIS AREA. TWENTY O'DONNELL.
BOARD WICKS. WE'RE GOING TO
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR MEMBERS
TO ADD ON I WANT TO NOTE THAT
AB SEVEN NINETY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RAMOS WAS
NOTICED IN THE DAILY FILE BUT
WILL NOT BE HEARD TODAY IT WILL
BE HEARD AT A LATER HEARING WE
HAVE FIVE BILLS TO DISCUSS
TODAY A. B. NINE SEVENTEEN AB
ONE SEVENTEEN EIGHTY NINE
EIGHTY FOUR AB FIFTEEN OH THREE
MAYBE ELEVEN FORTY SEVEN WE
HAVE OUR FIRST AUTHOR
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM. I WOULD
INVITE YOU AT YOUR WHEN YOU'RE
READY TO OPEN ON THE BILL.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND- WHAT
BETTER WAY TO HONOR THE MEMORY
OF SENATOR MILLS AND WITH A
TRANSIT FRIENDLY BILL WHICH AB
NINE SEVENTEEN CERTAINLY AS IT
WILL. EXPANSIVE LAW TO ALLOW
TRANSIT AGENCIES TO CAPTURE
IMAGES OF VEHICLES. VIOLATING
TRANSIT ONLY LANES AND BLOCKING
BUS STOPS. BUS ONLY LANES OF
COURSE ARE AN IMPORTANT TRANSIT
INFRASTRUCTURE YET DESPITE
CLEAR MARKINGS AND SIGNAGE.
THESE LANES ARE FREQUENTLY
IGNORED. FOR EXAMPLE FIELD
OBSERVATIONS OF WILSHIRE
BOULEVARD IN WEST LOS ANGELES
AND MY DISTRICT FOUND ONE
VIOLATION EVERY FOUR MINUTES.
BUS ONLY LANE VIOLATIONS AND
PARKED VEHICLES CAUSE DELAYS
AND POSE SAFETY ISSUES TO
RIDERS TRANSIT OPERATORS ARE
FORCED TO MANEUVER AROUND
CONGESTED LANES AND MAKE DROP
OFFS FURTHER FROM THE CURB.
CAMERA ENFORCEMENT PROGRAMS
HAVE BEEN IMPLEMENTED IN SAN
FRANCISCO ALAMEDA AND CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY TO DETER DRIVERS
FROM IMPEDING RELIABLE SERVICE.
FORWARD FACING CAMERAS ARE
TESTS OF THE BUSES AND ONLY
RECORD LICENSE PLATES OF
VEHICLES BLOCKING BUS LANES
IMAGES ARE THEN SENT TO THE
LOCAL ENFORCEMENT AGENCY TO
REVIEW AND ISSUE A CITATION IF
NEEDED. THESE CAMERA
ENFORCEMENT PROGRAMS SHOWED
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTIONS IN
VIOLATIONS AND DECREASE
VARIABILITY AND TRAVEL TIMES IN
JUST THEIR PILOT PHASE SAN
FRANCISCO SHOWED A 20%
REDUCTION IN DELAYS AND EVEN
FEWER REPEAT VIOLATORS. IN
ALAMEDA AND CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
AC TRANSIT SAW 21% INCREASE IN
ON TIME PERFORMANCE. THE CAMERA
ENFORCEMENT WORKS IN THIS
SETTING AND IT'S COST EFFECTIVE
AND IDEAL FOR BUSY STREETS
WHERE PARKING IS ENFORCEMENT IS
NOT REALISTIC. AB NINE
SEVENTEEN WILL PROVIDE RIDERS
WITH ACCESS TO SAFE AND RAPID
BUS SERVICE AND ENSURE PUBLIC
TRANSIT REMAINS COMPETITIVE IN
ATTRACTING MORE RIDERS. I WANT
TO NOTE THAT- I'LL BE AMENDING
THE BILL TO REMOVE THE WORK
STATIONS FROM THE LANGUAGE OF
THE BILL THERE WERE CONCERNS
THAT ENFORCEMENT TRANSIT
STATIONS WOULD INCLUDE PARKING
LOTS AND THAT WAS NOT OUR
INTENTION WE'RE GOING TO
THEREFORE AMEND THE BILL IN THE
NEXT COMMITTEE. TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL- WE HAVE
DESIREE JONES A SENIOR MANAGER
OF LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS AT L. A.
METRO AND CLAUDIA BURGERS
DIRECTOR OF LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS
AND COMMUNITY AND COMMUNITY
RELATIONS AT AC TRANSIT. THANK
YOU- OPERATOR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CAN YOU BRING US- THE
WITNESSES I THINK DESIREE JONES
WILL BE SPEAKING FIRST YOU CAN
FIND DESIREE JONES FOR US. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU CHAIR
AND MEMBERS FOR HEARING EIGHTY
NINE ONE SEVEN TODAY THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOW FOR
OFFERING THE BILL I'M DESIREE
JOHN HERE ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY OR L.
A. METRO EIGHTY NINE ONE SEVEN
WOULD AUTHORIZE PUBLIC TRANSIT
AGENCIES AT ALL FRONT FACING
CAMERAS ON ITS TRANSIT VEHICLE
DISTRICTS WOULD ENFORCEMENT OF
PARKING VIOLATIONS IN TRANSIT
ONLY LANES. AND AT BUS STOPS
WITH THIS IS DORIE METRO AND
OTHER TRANSIT AGENCIES CAN
PARTNER WITH LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS THAT ALREADY HAVE
PARKING ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY
IN LA COUNTY AND THROUGHOUT THE
STATE METRO SPONSORING EIGHTY
NINE ONE SEVEN TO AUTHORIZE THE
DEPLOYMENT OF THE TRANSIT LANE
ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE CITIES OF
LOS ANGELES AND SANTA MONICA
HERE IN L. A. COUNTY WHERE WE
OPERATE OVER TWENTY NINE MILES
OF EXISTING BUSTLING. AND THIS
WOULD ALSO ALLOW FOR FUTURE
EXPANSION AND PARTNERSHIP WITH
OTHER CITIES IN LA COUNTY AND
METRO BUS RAPID. TRANSIT LANE
NETWORK GROWS. METRO CURRENT
SERVES THE TEN READ IN AT LAKE.
A MAJORITY WHICH ARE IN THE OF
LA. DURING THE PANDEMIC WE
CONTINUE TO SERVE OVER FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND WRITERS PER
DAY WITH 75% OF OUR RIDERSHIP
ON BUDGET. MEASURE WILL EXPAND
OUR NET NETWORK TO OVER A
HUNDRED MILES IN THE NEXT
DECADE DECADE. IMPROVING SPEED
AND RELIABILITY OF OUR BUS
NETWORK YOU EIGHTY NINE ONE
SEVEN IS ESSENTIAL TO MOVING
MORE PEOPLE I'M TRANSIT BUSES
INCREASE MOBILITY. AND
ULTIMATELY REDUCING GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS. ILLEGALLY PARKED
CARS IN BOTH LANES IS A SAFETY
HAZARD EIGHTY NINE ONE SEVEN
WILL HELP BUT HIS TO OPERATE
FASTER AND MORE SAFELY. FOR
EXAMPLE A SINGLE CAR THAT THE
LEGALLY PARKED IN A BUCKLEY OF
EIGHTY BUCKS RIGHT WRITERS ARE
DELAYED EACH MINUTE WE'RE
TALKING FIVE THOUSAND RIDERS
DELETE IN THE HOUR. BEFORE
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT IS ABLE
TO CLEAR THE BUS PLANE FOR
SERVICE. WE JUST WANT TO BUILD
ON THE SUCCESS OF SAN FRANCISCO
AND EIGHTY TRANSIT PROGRAM-
THAT WAS REACHED. PREVIOUSLY
AUTHORIZED. BY STANDING UP WITH
SIMILAR PROGRAMS HERE IN L. A.
COUNTY AND THAT INCLUDES THAT
CONCLUDES MY REMARKS FOR TODAY
AND THANK YOU AGAIN. I REQUEST
YOUR EITHER. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CAN WE HAVE OUR NEXT
WITNESS. AND SUPPORT CLAUDIA
BURGERS PLEASE. CRITERION MY
NUMBER. THANK YOU CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FOR HEARING THIS BILL
TODAY AND TAKE YOUR NUMBER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PORTAL FOR
INTRODUCING EIGHTY NINE ONE
SEVEN MY NAME IS PROBABLY A
GOOD WHAT DIRECTOR OF
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS AND
COMMUNITY RELATIONS THAT HE
TRANSIT EIGHTY TRANSIT CO
SPONSORING EIGHTY NINE ONE
SEVEN WHICH WILL ALLOW EIGHTY
TRANSIT TO CONTINUE THE
OPERATION OF ITS FORWARD FACING
CAMERAS ON THE- TEMPLE B. R. T.
LINE AND AUTHORIZED USED TO
DISCOURAGE VEHICLES ILLEGALLY
PARKED AT TRANSIT STOPS. EIGHTY
NINE ONE SEVEN AIMS TO IMPROVE
TO PROVIDE PAPER MORE RELIABLE
AND MORE ACCEPTABLE TRANSIT
SERVICE IT BUILDS UPON EXISTING
LAW BY ALLOWING ALL CALIFORNIA
TRANSIT AGENCIES TO USE CAMERAS
MOUNTED ON TRANSIT VEHICLES TO
DISCOURAGE ILLEGAL PARKING IN
TRANSIT ONLY LANES AND AT
TRAFFIC STOP BY REDUCING THE
DISRUPTIONS AND DELAYS CAUSED
BY NON TRANSIT VEHICLES ILLEGAL
ILLEGALLY PARKED IN TRANSIT
LANES AND FIVE. EIGHTY NINE ONE
SEVEN WOULD IMPROVE TRANSIT
SYSTEM ACCESSIBILITY SAFETY AND
RELIABILITY WELL ADVANCING
EQUITY FOR TRANSIT RIDERS
CURRENT LAW ALLOWS EASY TRANSIT
DISCOURAGE ILLEGAL PARKING IN
THE TRANSIT ONLY LANES OF OUR
NEW BUS RAPID TRANSIT SYSTEM
TEMPLE THE CAMERAS MOUNTED ON
TEMPLE COACHES HAVE PLAYED AN
IMPORTANT ROLE IN DISCOURAGING
ILLEGAL PARKING IN THE SYSTEM
TRANSIT ONLY LANES AS A RESULT
THANK YOU FOR DRIVERS AND
RIDERS HAVE IMPROVED ALONG THE
ROUTE AND OUR SERVICE IS
ATTAINING A REMARKABLE ON ON
TIME PERFORMANCE OF 82% AS OF
LAST WEEK. THE SAFETY AND
RELIABILITY OF OUR REGULAR
SERVICES FREQUENTLY COMPROMISED
WHEN VEHICLES PARKED IN MY SPOT
WHENEVER THE PRINTER IS NOT
ABLE TO REACH THE CURB WRITERS
ARE FORCED TO LOAD AND UNLOAD
IN THE STREET OR NEGOTIATE THE
LARGE GAP THAT IS CREATED
BETWEEN THE BUT IN THE CURRENT
THIS IS A POTENTIALLY DANGEROUS
MANEUVER FOR WRITERS TO MAKE AN
IMPOSSIBLE ONE FOR SENIORS AND
THOSE WITH A DISABILITY OR
MOBILITY LIMITATIONS. VEHICLES
BLOCKING BUT THAT MAKE IT
DIFFICULT FOR SENIORS SIX
DIFFICULT FOR SENIORS TO GET
FROM BUS FOR BICYCLISTS HELLO
THERE BIKE. FROM THE BIKE RACK
AND THEY CREATE AN THEY'VE
CONDITION FOR EVERYONE ON THE
ROAD. IN OTHER VEHICLE AND
PEDESTRIANS. LASTLY 75% OF
EIGHTY TRY RIDERS ARE PEOPLE
COLOR IN 60% ARE LOW IN.
IMPROVING THE ON TIME BEFORE
UPON TRANSIT. FOR THOSE RELY ON
THE THIRD AS A MATTER OF EQUITY
FOR PUBLIC TRANSIT RIDERS IF
YOU CAN FINISH PLEASE TRANSIT
IS COMMITTED. OKAY IF YOU CAN
FINISH UP YOUR WE ARE TRYING TO
COPE. NINE SEVEN THANK YOU FOR
TIME I WOULD YOUR ITEM. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I DON'T HAVE ANY
LISTED OPPOSITION ON FILE- I
WILL NOW SEE IF THERE'S ANY
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM SEEING
NONE. I DON'T THINK THEY'RE ANY
WITNESSES AT THE REMOTE
LOCATION. THERE ARE NONE SO
OPERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE OPEN
THE PHONES FOR REMOTE-
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE FOUR
LINES IN Q. OVER TO LINE
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR BOB ROBINSON
LEGISLATIVE REPRESENTATIVE FOR
THE CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION WE ARE ALSO ONE OF
THE CO SPONSORS OF THIS BILL
AND WE ENCOURAGE YEAR I MOVED
TODAY AND BELIEVES IN THE
SAFETY AND RANSIT
IMPROVEMENTS. BOB THIS BILL
COULD BRING FORWARD. THANK YOU
FOR NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. THANK
YOU RIGHT TWENTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
THE WALL COMING UP THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
COORDINATE TRANSIT ALSO NOR CAL
ACT IN SUPPORT OF AB NINE ONE
SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT YEAR PLEASE RIGHT.
THANK YOU I'M THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
ANTILLES SHAW ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY CITY OF SANTA MONICA AND
OUR BIG MOVE BUT- PART OF THE
BILL TO IMPROVE SERVICE AND-
SAFETY WE- ABOUT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS
TIME. OVER TO ONE TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MA'AM TERM MEMBERS THIS IS ROSS
BARKLEY ON BEHALF OF STAND BY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINE ONE SEVEN.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU WITHOUT WILL THENGO
TO THE COMMITTEE TO SEE IF
THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
MR WARD. THANK YOU CAN CHARGE
ONE THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
INTRODUCING THIS BILL- PRIOR TO
COMING BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE
IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT I ACTUALLY
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO PILOT A
BUS ONLY LANE THAT HAS THE
INTENTION OF BEING ABLE TO
IMPROVE THE TIMELINESS AND
EFFICIENCY OF ONE OF OUR MOST
HEAVILY USED ROUTES IN THE SAN
DIEGO AND THE DEPOSIT FRANCIS
SYSTEM JURISDICTION SO I THINK
ON THIS BILL WILL GO A LONG WAY
TO MAKING SURE THAT WE WILL BE
EFFECTIVE- AND ACHIEVING THOSE
AN INCREASE THAT TRANSIT.
NETWORKS AND I KNOW WE WANT TO
BE ABLE TO ACHIEVE AND THEN I
WILL LOOKING AT OTHER- ARE
POTENTIAL BUS ONLY LANES AS
WELL SO THANK YOU FOR OFFERING
THIS AND HAPPY TO. MOVE THE
BILL IF IT'S APPROPRIATE. THANK
YOU ANYBODY ELSE. WE HAVE A
MOTION TO HAVE A STAR AND A
SECOND I AM VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
THE BILL I WILL I KNOW THAT THE
BILL IS MOVING TO PRIVACY AND
CONSUMER PROTECTION NEXT TO ANY
OUTSTANDING CONCERNS WILL BE
ADDRESSED THERE- MISTER BLOOM
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
CAN WE HAVE A ROLL CALL PLEASE.
FOR THE MOTION IS THE PATH TO
THE PRO. SUMER PROTECTION
COMMITTEE FRIEDMAN. HI FRIEDMAN
I FALL FONG I BERMAN. BERMAN I
CUNNINGHAM. DALY DALY AYE
DAVIES DAVIES I'D GIPSON GIPSON
AYE KALRA. KALRA I LEE LEE I
MEDINA MEDINA I THIS AREA. WHEN
WELL DONALD. WARD WARD I WICKS.
TEN ZERO OKAY THE BILL IS NOT
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU. WE HAVE OUR
NEXT AUTHOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH WHO IS AB ONE
ONE SEVEN WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
YOU MAY PROCEED. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS FIRST OF
ALL I'D LIKE TO TREAT THANK
MADAM CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE
STUFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL. TODAY I AM PRESENTING AB
ONE ONE SEVEN. TO PROVIDE A
REBATE PROGRAM FOR THE PURCHASE
OF ELECTRIC BICYCLES OR E.
BIKES. EVOKES ARE CLEAN AND
HEALTHY FORMER TRANSPORTATION
THANK CREE THINKING ABOUT
ADOPTION WE'RE REDUCING VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED. A RECENT STUDY
OF NORTH AMERICAN E. BIKE
OWNERS SHOW THAT NEARLY HALF OR
FORTY SIX PERCENT. OF THE BY
COMMUTING TRIPS REPLACE
AUTOMOBILE COMMUTE TRIPS. TO
ADDRESS CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE
GOALS WE MUST WORK TO REDUCE.
THESE VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED
AND REPLACE THEM WITH CLEANER
ALTERNATIVES. IF I COULD OFFER
HAS INCREASED SIGNIFICANTLY
OVER THE PAST YEARS BUT COST
REMAINING FACTORS IN
AVAILABILITY FOR MANY
CALIFORNIANS AB ONE ONE SEVEN
WILL MAKE E. BIKES MORE
AFFORDABLE TO CALIFORNIANS.
ALLOWING MORE PEOPLE TO ADOPT
THIS GREENER HEALTHIER FORMER
TRANSPORTATION I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOE. TODAY I
HAVE TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL CORINNA CONTRERAS
COUNCIL MEMBER OF THE CITY OF
THE STUFF AND DAVE SNYDER
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA BICYCLE COALITION.
THE SPONSOR OF THIS BILL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH LET'S GO FIRST TO
OUR WITNESS ON THE PHONE
KATRINA CONTRASTS OPERATOR.
BRAINERS YOU ARE DIALED IN
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO SO I
CAN OPEN YOUR LINE. DAVE SURE
LET'S GO TO DAVE SNYDER- IN THE
WITNESS FROM PLEASE. A GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARE GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. OKAY MY
NAME'S DAVE SNYDER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BICYCLE COALITION
OUR ORGANIZATION WORKS FOR
BETTER COMMUNITIES ESPECIALLY
MORE EQUITABLE COMMUNITIES.
WHERE RESIDENTS CAN BENEFIT
FROM THE ECONOMY AND THE HEALTH
AND THE JOY OF BICYCLING FOR
MORE ABOUT COMMUNITIES AND WE
ARE ABOUT THE MACHINE ITSELF.
WHICH IS WHY WE LOVE THIS BILL.
HI GETTING AROUND BY ANY KIND
OF BIKE IS FUN BUT E. BIKES ARE
SPECIAL AND THEIR UTILITY FOR
TRANSPORTATION. THEY MAKE
PREVIOUSLY IMPRACTICAL TRICKS
SUDDENLY PRACTICAL- THAT STUDY
OF NORTH AMERICAN E. BIKE USERS
THAT THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER CITED
ALSO DISCOVERED THAT THE TOP
FOUR REASONS PEOPLE CITED FOR
NOT BIKING FOR TRANSPORTATION.
ARE THERE TOO MANY HILLS THE
DISTANCES TO FAR THEY DIDN'T
WANT TO ARRIVE SWEATY BIKING
WAS TOO SLOW. E. BIKES TAKE
AWAY ALL THOSE REASONS THAT
FLATTENED HILLS REMOVE
HEADWINDS THEY MAKE IT SO YOU
DON'T HAVE TO GET SWEATY TO GO
FAST. YEAH PEOPLE TO RIDE BIKES
IS CRITICAL BECAUSE AS WAS
MENTIONED WE NEED TO REDUCE OUR
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION GOALS
WE SIMPLY CAN'T AFFORD IT'S NOT
POSSIBLE TO QUICKLY ENOUGH
ELECTRIFY OUR CAR FLEET WE HAVE
TO GIVE PEOPLE. GOOD
ALTERNATIVES TO THE CAR AND THE
BIKE IS A GREAT ALTERNATIVE.
THAT SAME STUDY FOUND THAT OF
THE E. BIKE USERS WHO HAD NOT
RIDDEN A BIKE AS AN ADULT. 94%
OF THEM BECAME DAILY OR WEEKLY
RIGHT SO IT REALLY IS THE THING
THAT GETS SOMEONE TO RIDE A
BIKE AND HAD RIDDEN A BIKE
BEFORE IT'S A GREAT ALTERNATIVE
TO A CAR THIS PROGRAM GETS
IMPLEMENTED. WE CAN SUPPORT
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS WITH A FANTASTIC
HEALTHY MOBILITY OPTION WITH
ZERO EMISSIONS. AND A VERY LOW
COST- WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR I VOTE AND I AM HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU FOR FINISHING UNDER TIME AS
WELL. OPERATOR DO WE HAVE OUR
SECOND WITNESS ON THE PHONE. Q.
CURRENT AIRLINE AND OPEN. THANK
YOU SO MUCH I REALLY APPRECIATE
BEING INVITED HERE TO PROVIDE
SOME TESTIMONY ABOUT WHAT THEY
SEE ON A DAILY BASIS IN MY OWN
COMMUNITY MY NAME'S CORRINA
CONSIDERED OUTSIDE THE COUNCIL
MEMBER REPRESENTING DISTRICT
ONE IN THE CITY OF THIS STUFF.
IT IS A DISTRICT THAT HAS TWO
MAIN TRANSIT CORRIDORS IN A
DISTRICT WHERE A LOT OF
INDIVIDUALS. RESIDING USE
EITHER THEIR FEET TO WALK ONE
PLACE TO ANOTHER- THEY USED
BICYCLES. AND ONE THING THAT
I'VE NOTICED IS THAT I'VE SEEN
AN UPTICK IN INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE BIKING TO AND FROM WHERE
THEY NEED TO GO. I'VE SEEN MORE
E. BIKES ON THE ROAD BUT WHAT I
DEFINITELY SEE IS A BIG DIVIDE
BETWEEN THOSE WHO CAN AFFORD AN
INVITE AND THOSE WHO CAN'T. SO
WHAT IS POSSIBLE WITH A YES
VOTE ON AB ONE SEVENTEEN. IS
THAT WE CAN MOVE TOWARDS
EMBRACING MORE ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION. WHILE WEARING
R. V. AND T. AND PROVIDING A
MORE SUSTAINABLE AND EQUITABLE
MULTI MODAL TRANSPORTATION
OPTION. NOW YOU KNOW HE BY.
REAL AN EQUITABLE SOLUTION FOR
MANY FOLKS EVERY DAY
TRANSPORTATION MEANS ESPECIALLY
FOR FIRST AND LAST MILE
PROBLEMS. THE CURRENT COSTS TO
BE BY MAKES THEM INACCESSIBLE
TO MOST IN OUR COMMUNITY
ESPECIALLY FOR FAMILIES WITH
CHILDREN THAT WOULD NEED TO
PURCHASE SEVERAL QUITE. I
REALLY WANT TO DATE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH FOR
TAKING UP THIS BILL AND WORKING
TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE FROM ALL
BACKGROUNDS TO TAKE PART IN A
MORE SUSTAINABLE FUTURE FOR OUR
STATE. NOW FAIR ENOUGH YOU CAN
FINISH YOUR TIME RESULT. SURE
IF WE DON'T MOVE FORWARD I AM
REALLY CONCERNED. THAT PEOPLE
MIGHT COMMUNITY ARE NOT GOING
TO HAVE THE ACCESS TO EAT BY
THAT THE NEED AND THAT THEY
SHOULD HAVE THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I DON'T SEE
I HAVE NO WITNESSES- IS
SCHEDULED IN OPPOSITION I DON'T
SEE ANYONE IN THE ROOM TO
TESTIFY DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES. IN THE- OF WITNESS
TESTIMONY ROOM. NOPE OKAY THAT
OPERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE GO TO
THE PHONE LINES AND OPEN UP THE
PHONE LINES FOR ANY WITNESSES.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN I YOU WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE
HAVE ABOUT FOUR IN THE QUEUE
IT'LL JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR
THE FIRST ONE THANK YOU.
OVER
TWENTY EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DAVID I WOULD BE A ASSOCIATE
STATE DIRECTOR FOR AARP
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU NINE
THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS WHO AROUND OFF WITH THE
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NINE TWENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I GOT
TWENTY NINE. YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD I'M SORRY ABOUT THAT MY
MANY TECHNIQUE OFTEN I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF LOCAL FOR
CALIFORNIA AND THE CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT YOU LIKE KERN OFFICIAL
PART OF THE TRANSITION AWAY
FROM PERSONAL VEHICLE AND
POPLITEAL CONSUMPTION- THE
BIGGEST IMPEDIMENT IS REALLY
THE CALL- AND SO THE BILL IS AN
INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITY TO
BECOME MORE ACCESSIBLE TO
EVERYONE AND CREATE GREATER
SOCIETAL BENEFITS NOT
CONDITIONALLY FROM POP APPEAL.
I ENCOURAGE EVERYBODY TO VOTE
YES ON THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AGAIN YOU
WISH TO MAKE A COME PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO THIS TIME
WHAT'S LINE TWENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME'S
BRIAN SIMMONS I AM SEVENTY FOUR
YEARS OLD AND I LIVE IN OAKLAND.
I LOST MY LEG TO CANCER TEN
YEARS AGO LEAVING A FULLY
DISABLED MOBILITY IMPAIRED AND
EMOTIONALLY DEVASTATED. BECAUSE
OF THE GENEROSITY OF MY FAMILY
I WAS ABLE TO PURCHASE AN
ELECTRIC ASSIST RECUMBENT
BICYCLE AND I BEGAN THE SLOW
RECOVERY TO CRITICAL AND
EMOTIONAL L. E. BIKE OPENED UP
A WHOLE NEW WORLD OF MOBILITY
AND ACCESSIBILITY GIVING ME
EASY FLEXIBLE ACCESS. TO THE
ENTIRE EACH DAY. I'D LIKE TO
THE GROCERY STORE AND TO ALL MY
ERRANDS I EVEN BICYCLE TO GET
MICHAEL JOBS MY YOU MIGHT LIKE
IT'S ALSO GREAT FOR EXERCISE
AND RECREATION HELPING ME KEEP
UP WITH OTHER APRIL CYCLIST AND
TO GET TO PLACES THAT WOULD.
OTHERWISE BE INACCESSIBLE TO ME.
PLEASE THE ONCE. TO GIVE OTHERS.
THE ACT TO MOBILITY. AND JOY OF
LIFE THAT I NOW EXPERIENCE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON AUDRA
HARTMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE ONE SEVEN
AND ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT AS
WELL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
LET'S GO TO THE TECHNICIAN TO
SEE IF THERE ARE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. SEEING NONE I'M
FULLY SUPPORTIVE OF THIS BILL
AND I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING IT FORWARD- I'D
LIKE TO BE OUT OF A AS A CO
AUTHOR FROM NOT ONE ALREADY I
DON'T EVEN KNOW- DO YOU HAVE
ANY WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. NO
I RESPECTFULLY ASK HER FOR YOUR
I DON'T I WOULD LOVE TO ADD YOU
AS A CO AUTHOR DOING OFTEN.
THANK YOU. WE HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND CAN WE HAVE A ROLL
CALL PLEASE. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
FRIEDMAN. HI FRIEDMAN I FALL.
SEVEN NUMBER ELEVEN BERMAN.
BERMAN HIGH CUNNINGHAM. DALY
DALY AYE DAVIES. NOT MONNING
GIPSON- GIPSON I KALRA. KALRA I
LEE LEE I MEDINA MEDINA I
NAZARIAN. WHEN O'DONNELL. WARD
WARD I. THE. EIGHT ZERO. EIGHT
ZERO THE BILL IS OUT. WE WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU. SO WE ARE
LOOKING FOR AN AUTHOR EITHER
HIS RIVAS FOR MR SANTIAGO. ARE
EITHER OF THEM- IN THE REMOTE
ROOM OKAY. I THINK THAT GIVEN
THAT I WILL DO MY BILL NOW NO
PASSED THE GAVEL MR FONG. MADAM
CHAIR BEGIN- WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY THANK YOU MEMBERS AB
ELEVEN FORTY SEVEN TAKES A
MULTI FACETED APPROACH TO SET
CALIFORNIA ON THE COURSE TO
MEET THE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSION REDUCTION TARGETS. BUT
MAKING CHANGES AT THE STATE
LOCAL AND REGIONAL LEVELS TO
PROVIDE TOOLS ACCOUNTABILITY
AND INCENTIVES FOR METROPOLITAN
PLANNING ORGANIZATIONS TO MEET
THEIR TWENTY THIRTY FIVE
REGIONAL GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSION TARGETS. SB THREE
SEVENTY FIVE THE SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES AND CLIMATE
PROTECTION ACT OF TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT. WAS A FIRST OF ITS KIND
LAW TO RECOGNIZE THE CRITICAL
ROLE OF INTEGRATED
TRANSPORTATION LAND USE AND
HOUSING DECISIONS TO MEET STATE
CLIMATE GOALS. SB THREE SEVENTY
FIVE REQUIRES EACH OF
CALIFORNIA'S EIGHTEEN REGIONAL
METROPOLITAN PLANNING
ORGANIZATIONS. TO INCLUDE A NEW
ELEMENT IN THEIR LONG RANGE
REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION PLANS.
A SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES
STRATEGY. V. THIS S. C. S.
IDENTIFY STRATEGIES TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS AND GAS
EMISSIONS FROM DRIVING WHICH OF
COURSE LEADS TO HEALTHIER AND
MORE EQUITABLE AND SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES. HOWEVER REPORTS
FROM THE AIR RESOURCE BOARD OF
THE L. A. O. AND OTHERS HAVE
STATED THAT CALIFORNIA IS NOT
ON TRACK TO REALIZE THE GHG
EMISSION REDUCTIONS THAT
EXPECTS. UNDER SB THREE SEVENTY
FIVE OR THE IMPORTANT CO
BENEFITS. THIS BILL REQUIRES
EACH MPO TO CREATE A TARGET
ACTION PLAN TO DEVELOP AND
DEVELOP A NEW BLOCK GRANT
PROGRAMS. TO PROVIDE FUNDING TO
THESE NPOS TO ACHIEVE THEIR
GOALS. TODAY I HAVE AN AND AS
WE MOVE THROUGH THE PROCESS OF
COURSE WE WILL CONTINUE TO
ENGAGE ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS.
AND I'M COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH EVERYONE TO STRIKE THE
RIGHT BALANCE TO GET STATE
REGIONAL AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ALL WORKING TOGETHER. ON THESE
IMPORTANT GOALS TODAY I HAVE
CARTER RUBIN FROM NRDC AND WILL
BEAR IT FROM THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. WITH THAT I HUMBLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB ELEVEN
FORTY SEVEN. I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR OPERATOR- MAYBE PROCEED
WITH WITNESSES. THE OPERATOR.
YES THEIR LIVES ARE OPEN. OKAY-
THE FIRST ONE IS YOU MAY
PROCEED. PRINTER NUMBER BECAUSE
WE'VE BEEN WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HERE TODAY TO EXPECT ENERGY
SUPPORT WORK AT ELEVEN FORTY
SEVEN. WHICH WILL ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S EFFORTS TO HALT
CLIMATE CHANGE THE CENTER
LARGER THIRTY GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS TRANSPORTATION SECTOR.
ALL ARE ALREADY SUFFERING FROM
THE DEVASTATING IMPACT CLIMATE
CHANGE RECORDER QUALITY. AND
DESPITE INCREASINGLY FREQUENT
UNPRECEDENTED DISASTERS WE
CONTINUE TO INVEST IN
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT POINT MORE
FUEL ON THE FIRE. OUR STATE
AGENCIES BRADY BILL ARM BUT OUR
CURRENT TRANSPORTATION POLICIES
PUSHING MORE ROADS MODERATE.
BETWEEN GENERATE MORE DRIVING.
AB ELEVEN FORTY SEVEN BUILT ON
A FOUNDATION OF WORKERS AT THE
THREE SEVENTY FIVE RECOGNIZE
THAT FGHTING CLIMATE CHANGE ME
GIVING CALIFORNIANS SOMETHING
THEY CONSISTENTLY ASKED FOR.
THE ABILITY TO GET AROUND
WITHOUT GETTING IN THEIR CAR.
THANK THE AIR B. TWENTY
EIGHTEEN PROGRESS REPORT WE
KNOW THAT CALIFORNIA'S NOT ON
TRACK. NEEDED. THEY ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT REDUCING VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED IF NECESSARY TO
HIT OUR CLINICAL. THE PORTION
OF COMMUTERS DRIVING ON TO WORK
WHAT'S THAT ONLY RISING
ENDEMIC. IN ALMOST EVERY REGION.
AND UNDERSTAND CALIFORNIA IS
EXPECTED TO SPEND A TRILLION
DOLLARS IN THE LIFE OF ALL
CURRENT TRANSPORTATION PLAN.
WOULD BE FINED OR NOT ALIGNED
WITH OUR CLINICAL. WE
APPRECIATE THAT AB A ONE FORTY
SEVEN WELL SHIFTED. BY LINING
OUR STREETS TRANSPORTATION
INVESTMENTS BUT THE PRIORITY.
IS TO MAKE SURE REGIONAL PLAN
TO HELPING TO REDUCE DRIVING
AND IMPROVE ALTERNATIVE DRIVING.
THIS BILL CREATE THE PROCESS TO
GET REGION BACK ON TRACK YOU
NEED A CLINICAL IT COULD BE
CORRECTIVE ACTION PLAN. AND
THIS BILL THE POOR TEENAGER
INVESTMENT IN REDUCING VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED AT A LOCAL
LEVEL. WE KNOW THERE'S HUGE
PENT UP DEMAND FOR THE- USE OF
THE LAST ROUND OF ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION GRANT. OVER TWO
BILLION DOLLARS IN FUNDING
REQUEST CAME IN. SPENT TIME
BEING OUT THE PDP AT THE
ALLOCATE. THANK YOU JEFFREY
CLEARLY SUPPOSED. ISSUE AND
ENERGY FEARED DIRECTLY MEMBERS
BY. I THANK VERY MUCH THE
SECOND ONE IS A PRETTY. HI
THANK YOU I'M WILL PERISH I'M
THE DIRECTOR OF CLEAN AIR
ADVOCACY FOR THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION. THE TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR IS THE LEADING SOURCE OF
CALIFORNIANS ARE POOR AIR AND
CLIMATE POLLUTION WITHOUT A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO
HEALTHIER MORE SUSTAINABLE
TRANSPORTATION THAT SERVES ALL
RESIDENTS CALIFORNIA WILL NOT
MEET OUR HEALTH PROTECTIVE
CLEANER CLIMATE ENTERED. LAND
USE AND TRANSPORTATION PLANNING
CENTRAL TO THIS DISCUSSION AND
WE ARE NOT ON TRACK TO
ACHIEVING THE CLIMATE
HEALTHEQUITY CONSERVATION AND
SUSTAINABILITY GOALS THAT WERE
CENTRAL SB THREE SEVENTY FIVE.
AB ELEVEN FORTY SEVEN REALLY
IT'S AN IMPORT TOLD HIM ON SB
THREE FIVE SECURE THE BENEFITS
OF HELP YOUR COMMUNITIES FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS. THIS IS
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT FOR MOST
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WHERE
RESIDENTS ARE OFTEN DEALING
WITH CHRONIC HEALTH BURDENS DUE
TO THE LACK OF HELP YOU
TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS. AND
HIGH LEVELS OF POLLUTION
LOCALLY. AT ELEVEN FORTY SEVEN
WOULD SUPPORT GETTING
CALIFORNIA BACK ON TRACK BY
BRINGING LOCAL REGIONAL AND
STATE AGENCIES TOGETHER TO
IDENTIFY BARRIERS TO ACHIEVING
A REGIONAL CLIMATE GOALS. AND
ADD THE TWENTY THIRTY FIVE
TARGET ACTION PLAN TO IDENTIFY
WHAT THE KEY BARRIERS ARE TO
PROGRESS. WHERE ARE THE AREAS
OF INVESTMENT THAT EITHER
SUPPORT OR DETRACT FROM TARGET
TREATMENT- IMPORTANTLY OUR TO
AND EVEN MORE IMPORTANTLY
REPORTS OF INPUT FROM
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES INTO
THE PLAN. AND THEN FINALLY
CORRECTIVE ACTION ITEMS- FOR
THE TENANT HERE TO MEET AT
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE REGIONAL
GREENHOUSE GAS TARGET. AS NOTED
THE BILL ALSO PROVIDES FOR
BLOCK GRANT FUNDING THAT CAN
SUPPORT THE ACTIONS NEEDED TO
BE TAKEN TO ACHIEVE THE TARGET
AND THE LOCAL. HEALTH BENEFITS.
THE BOARD HELP MUST THAT THE
POINT THAT WERE THERE FULL.
SPENT LINE WITH A SHEET HELP
THEIR- RATHER AT WORK THEN WE
ACROSS PURPOSES. SO WE'RE
LOOKING. ON BEHALF THE AMERICAN
TO. THE PATH DISPLAY. AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WERE WITH
STAKEHOLDERS A THE BOARD FROM
OUR- LOCAL GOVERNMENTS REGIONAL
AGENCIES AND AT THE STATE LEVEL
TO MAKE SURE. WE'RE MAKING
PROGRESS. IN GETTING BACK ON
TRACK THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I
THANK YOU. HI DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES OPPOSITION I DON'T
BELIEVE WE DO BUT OPERATOR IF
THERE WERE ANY WITNESSES
OPPOSITION WILL TAKE THAT NOW.
HEARING NONE. WILL MOVE TO THE
ROOM AND CHAMBERS I NOTICES IN
THE CHAMBERS. OPERATOR WHAT
DOES THEIR ANY OTHER WITH THE
OTHER INDIVIDUALS THAT WANT TO
SPEAK ON THIS BILL- ON THE
QUEUE. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE TWO IN HERE JUST BE ONE
MOMENT FOR THEIR FIRST COMMENT.
AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE OVER ONE
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON JULIE ARAMBULA WITH
THE COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THANK YOU I CURRENT. I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
OKAY- IN MY- AND MY CASE I
FORGOT TO SEE IF THERE WAS ANY
WITNESSES AND THE REMOTE.
TESTIFYING LOCATIONS. SEVEN
NINE A BRING OUT SO HAVE A BILL
HIGGINS THAT DIE OPEN OVER THE
PHONE AS A SPEAKER OKAY. HELLO
MISTER HAGENS- THANK YOU THIS
IS BILL HIGGINS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COUNCIL GOVERNMENTS WHICH IS
THE STATE ASSOCIATION THAT
REPRESENTS ALL EIGHTEEN
METROPOLITAN PLANNING
ORGANIZATIONS THAT WOULD BE
AFFECTED BY THE BILL WE DON'T
CURRENTLY HAVE A POSITION BUT
WE HAVE SOME HELPFUL COMMENTS
AND WE WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR HER LEADERSHIP ON THIS NOT
ONLY FOR PROPOSING THE FIRST.
QUARTER OF MONEY THAT WOULD GO
TO REGIONAL AGENCIES TO
IMPLEMENT THIS PROGRAM SPECIFIC
HOURS SB THREE SEVENTY FIVE
SPECIFICALLY IN THAT TEN YEARS
BUT IT'S BEEN EFFECTIVE BUT
ALSO FOR RECOGNIZING THAT THERE
IS A GAP BETWEEN WHAT OUR ROLE
OR THE REGIONAL ROLE IS AND
REDUCING. GHGS CERVANTES AND
ALSO THE ADDITIONAL STATE
ACTIONS FOR WHICH THERE IS A
PLAN RIGHT NOW AND SHE
IDENTIFIED IT AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT STATE REGIONAL
AND LOCAL PARTNERS NEED TO SIT
DOWN AND THINK ABOUT WE
APPRECIATE HER LEADERSHIP ON
THAT AND WILL CONTINUE WORKING.
WITH HER THROUGH THE PROCESS
THANK YOU. ATTACKING THE HAGENS-
OPERATOR ARE THERE ANY OTHER
CALLERS IN THE QUEUE. THANK YOU
I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
THANK YOU AT THE TIME. THANK
YOU OPERATOR I BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ARE THERE ANY
MEMBERS THAT WANT TO ASK ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR. I'LL
JUST I'LL JUST ABOVE I JUST ONE
QUESTION I WAS ONE OF YOU COULD
SPEAK- ABOUT IMPAIR ON JUST
LOCAL CONTROL AND HOW THIS
INTERACTS. THE REGIONAL
FRAMEWORK AND WHAT'S BEEN
DISCUSSED IN THE PAST ABOUT
CITIES AND COUNTIES HAVING.
CONTROL OVER THEIR THEIR OWN
MANDATORY. YES THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION- SO THE
BILL REALLY- ASKS THE LOCAL
PLANNING ENTITIES TO PLAN WITH
THE GOAL IN MIND OF REDUCING
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED AND
HELPING TO PROVIDE RESIDENTS
WITH MORE OPTIONS. TO WALK AND
BIKE AROUND THEIR COMMUNITIES-
SAFELY IT DOES NOT REQUIRE ANY
PARTICULAR METHOD OF DOING THAT
SO IT'S REALLY OPEN TO WHATEVER
FITS IN WITH THE LOCAL WITH THE
COMMUNITY. AND THAT'S GOING TO
LOOK VERY DIFFERENT IN DOWNTOWN
SACRAMENTO THAT WOULD LOOK IN
THE SUBURB AND IT WOULD LOOK IN
A RURAL AREA. SO IT'S CERTAINLY
NOT A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
APPROACH AND IT LEAVES OPEN TO
THE COMMUNITY TO FIND OUT WHAT
WHAT WORKS BEST FOR THEM AND I
WOULD. SUGGEST THAT HAVING THAT
LOCAL ABILITY TO PUSH THE
ENVELOPE AND EXPERIMENT IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT AT THIS
POINT. AND AS MR HIGGINS SAID
WE ARE IN CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE **** AND THE PLANNING
ENTITIES TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT IS WORKABLE
FOR THEM. I WE ARE ALSO IS HE
SAID FOR THE FIRST TIME
ATTEMPTING TO PROVIDE FUNDING
FOR THEM AS THEY DO THIS THESE
PLANNING EXERCISES. I DO WANNA
TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY TO ALSO
THANK MR HIGGINS FOR HIS HELP
WITH THIS AND- FOR. A REALLY
BEING A WONDERFUL PARTNER. A
CELEBRATION ANSWER ANY IN A NO
OTHER QUESTIONS- FROM THE
COMMITTEE. WE HAVE IN MOTION.
OKAY MOVED WILL MOVE A MOTION
TO A SECOND A SECOND. I'M CHAU
TACKLES. I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU SO MUCH
OF YOUR QUESTION. A SECRETARY
FEDERAL.THE MOTION IS TO PAST
TO NATURAL RESOURCES FRIEDMAN.
EVEN I FALL HELLO. BONO BERMAN
BERMAN I CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM
NO DALY. NOT VOTING SORRY ABOUT
THAT- DALY DALY I. DAVIES DAVID
NO GIPSON. GIPSON AYE KALRA. I
BELIEVE THREE I MEDINA MEDINA I
NAZARIAN. WHEN DONALD.
O'DONNELL HI WARD WARD HI. TO
NINE THREE THOSE NINE THREE
SEVEN BILLS OUT AND LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR AT THE NUMBERS.
THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIR- WE'RE
NOW GO BACK TO MR SANTIAGO WITH
AB FIFTEEN OH THREE WELCOME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS AB FIFTY THREE WOULD
ESTABLISH A PILOT PROGRAM TO
EVALUATE EVALUATE THE USE OF
DIGITAL DRIVERS LICENSES AND
ID'S BY TWENTY TWENTY SIX-
PHYSICAL IDEAS WILL- OFTENTIMES
COULD BE LOSS OF LEAVE PEOPLE
WITHOUT ANY SORT OF FORM IDEA
REPLACEMENT FOR WEEKS EVEN
DURING THIS PANDEMIC. I IN SOME
CASES- WERE WAS IMPOSSIBLE TO
GET A HOLD OF SOMEBODY DMV JUST
A SIMPLE REPLACEMENT- COULD
LAND SOMEBODY ANSWERS PROBLEMS.
I AM ALSO THINK YOU'RE YOU
MADAM CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
STAFFER HELPING TO SORT THIS
OUT AND- HOW DOES THE PRESENT
STATE THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE
DO A AND A SECOND- DO YOU HAVE
WITNESSES TODAY. NO WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT- I HAVE NOT ON FILE
IN OPPOSITION DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN THE WITNESS ROOM.
THANK YOU OPERATOR DO YOU HAVE
ANY WITNESSES ON THE TELEPHONE-
AND I SEE NO WITNESSES IN THE
VERY LARGE EMPTY ROOM- ANY
WITNESSES ON THE TELEPHONE
OPERATOR. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENTS
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU WITHOUT WILL GO TO THE
COMMITTEE TO SEE IF ANYONE HAS
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR
THE AUTHOR. SEEING NONE I DO
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
WORKING WITH US AND ACCEPTING-
OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE
MADE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSER.
RESPECTFUL OF AFRIN IDOL
MANAGER MEMBERS OKAY WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND. I BELIEVE.
CORRECT CAN WE PLEASE- CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
THROUGH PRICING CONSUMER
PROTECTION COMMITTEE FRIEDMAN
HI FRIEDMAN I FALL. FONG I
BERMAN. BERMAN I CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I DALY DALY AYE
DAVIES DAVIES I GIPSON- GIPSON
AYE KALRA. KALRA KILEY. LEE I
MEDINA MEDINA I NAZARIAN WHEN
O'DONNELL DONAL I WARD. WARD HI.
TWELVE TWELVE ZERO THE BILL IS
OUT WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT AUTHORS WE HAVE ONE
LAST BILL ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS
IS NINE EIGHTY FOUR SHE IS IN
ANOTHER COMMITTEE SO WE WILL
GIVE HER A FEW MINUTES
HOPEFULLY SHE CAN. CAN MAKE IT
UP HERE. UGH CAN WE CALL THE
ROLL ANOTHER BILLS THAT WERE
MISSED. BY MEMBERS OKAY LET'S
DO THAT.
ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. THE VOTE IS EIGHT
ZERO- BERMAN. BERMAN I
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I IN.
THIS AREA I WENT. O'DONNELL THE
DONALD I WORK. HI WARD AYE
HELLO.
THIRTEEN THIRTEEN ZERO.
FILE ITEM. ONE EIGHTY NINE
SEVENTEEN CURRENT VOTE TEN ZERO.
CUNNINGHAM I. NINE SEVENTEEN.
NINE SEVENTEEN CUNNINGHAM AYE
NAZARIAN NAZARIAN I WENT.
O'DONNELL. EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY.
FILE ITEM ONE. I DON'T WANNA
ASSEMBLY EVER BLOOM. NO NOT
VOTING- DAHLE NOT LOOKING.
CURVA. TWELVE ZERO. FILE ITEM
TO AB ONE SEVENTEEN CURRENT
VOTE EIGHT ZERO CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I NAZARIAN NAZARIAN
I WENT. O'DONNELL I. THE
CURRENT VOTE. ELEVEN ZERO. AND
JUST REMIND EVERYONE WE ARE
WAITING FOR ONE MORE AUTHOR SO
PLEASE DON'T LEAVE AFTER THE
ROLL IS CALLED. FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX AB. FIFTEEN ZERO
THREE. CURRENT VOTE. TWELVE
ZERO THIS AREA. WHEN NOBODY NOT
NOT VOTING WHEN. CURRENTLY.
TWELVE ZERO. FILE ITEM TWELVE
AB ELEVEN FORTY SEVEN CURRENTLY
NINE THREE NAZARIAN. THIS AREA
I WENT. CURRENTLY. TEN THREE.
FILE ITEM TWELVE A BILL AB
ELEVEN FORTY SEVEN. CURRENT
VOTE. TEN TO. MICHAEL OKAY.
SHE
TO BRING UP. AND HERE'S A QUICK
SUMMARY OF THE- ADDITION TO
ACCEPT. EACH SHE- A. IF YOU
DON'T. OKAY AND WE HAVE OUR
FINAL AUTHOR. THIS IS A AB
EIGHT NINE EIGHTY FOUR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THREE OF US WHENEVER YOU
ARE READY PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS I
WANT TO START BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR THOUGHTFUL
ANALYSIS I ALSO WANT EXCEPT THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS. LISTED ON
PAGE SIX OF THE ANALYSIS. AB
NINETY FOUR IMPLEMENTS FINDINGS
FOR THE VEHICLE REGISTRATION
ALTERNATIVE PILOT PROGRAMS. BY
AUTHORIZING THE DMV IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE CHP TO
DEVELOP REGULATIONS AND MOVE
FORWARD. WITH IMPLEMENTATION OF
ELECTRONIC REGISTRATION CARDS
DIGITAL LICENSE PLATES AND
LICENSE PLATE WRAPS. TODAY THE
DMB SPENDS ABOUT TWENTY FOUR
MILLION IN POSTAGE FOR THE
MAILING OF REGISTRATION RENEWAL
NOTICES AND NEW REGISTRATION
CARDS AND TAX THIS PROGRAM CAN
ALLOW THE DMV TO ACHIEVE COST
SAVINGS BY ELIMINATING THE NEED
FOR MAILING TAGS AND ALLOWING
USERS. ANOTHER WAY TO RENEW
VEHICLE REGISTRATION WITHOUT
VISITING A DMV FIELD OFFICE. IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN SB EIGHT OH SIX
AUTHORIZED THE DMV TO CREATE A
PILOT PROGRAM FOR VEHICLE
REGISTRATION ALTERNATIVES AND
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE ON
THE RESULTS OF THIS PILOT
PROGRAM. IN AUGUST OF TWENTY
NINETEEN THE DMV ISSUED THE
REPORT RECOMMENDING MOVING
FORWARD WITH THE THREE DEVICES
EVALUATED DURING THE PILOT. THE
PILOT PROGRAM ALLOW DIGITAL
PLATE OWNERS TO RENEW THE
REGISTRATION ELECTRONICALLY
THROUGH DIGITAL LICENSE PLATES
PROVIDER. AND THE MOBILE APP
ALLOWS INDIVIDUALS TO ACCESS
THE REGISTRATION INFORMATION
REMOTELY OVERALL THIS PILOT
PROGRAM FOUND THAT THESE
ALTERNATIVE REGISTRATION
PRODUCTS IMPROVED EFFICIENCY AT
THE DMV AND FOR CUSTOMERS.
TODAY I HAVE WITH ME TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY JIM LIGHTS
REPRESENTING REVIVER. THANK YOU
OPERATOR CAN WE PLEASE OPEN THE
LINE FOR MR LIGHTS. THANK YOU
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. H. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS JIM LIGHTS ON BEHALF OF
REVIVER THE MANUFACTURER OF THE
DIGITAL LICENSE PLATE ONE OF
THREE. AUTOX THAT WERE
EVALUATED DURING THE PILOT
PROGRAM WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE OUR
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE DEPARTMENT
AND OVER TIME BRING INCREASING
EFFICIENCIES TO THEIR OPERATION
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
I DO NOT HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ON FILE DO WE HAVE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
ANYWHERE- WE HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND I DON'T SEE ANY ONE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN THE
CHAMBERS TO HAVE ANYONE WISHING
TO SPEAK NO WE HAVE NO ONE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN THE REMOTE
LOCATION. OPERATOR COULD YOU
PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR
ANYONE WISHING TO VOICE THEIR-
FEELINGS ABOUT THE BILL. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WELL
FIRST FORTY NINE THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS JUSTIN HIGHER WITH THE
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP
WE'RE PROUD TO SUPPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU AT
YOUR MIND YOUR IF YOU WISH TO
MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU I'M NOW GOING TO
BRNG IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
MISTER GIBSON. WELL I'M SORRY
MR FONG. ADJUSTED A- FEW QUICK
QUESTIONS I- A TO THE AUTHOR- I
CERTAINLY SUPPORT THE
TECHNOLOGY- I KNOW WE SPOKE-
SPOKE BRIEFLY TODAY ABOUT. THE
AMBIGUITY ON REGARDING THAT THE
FEES OF THE AUTHORITY- IN THE
BILL IMMIGRATED IN ITS
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS NEW
PROGRAM. AND IT CERTAINLY
DOESN'T SPECIFY IN THE BILL-
THE DMV WOULD BE AUTHORIZED TO
CHARGE SO JUST THE THREE
QUESTIONS AND FEEL FREE TO
ANSWER. THEM AND ONE OF A TIME
WE'RE ALL TOGETHER- IS THAT IS
IT YOUR INTENT AT THE DMV OF
THE AUTHORIZED IMPOSED. FEES ON
ANY REGISTERED LICENSE HOLDER
OR JUST THOSE YOU PURCHASE A
DIGITAL LICENSE PLATE. AND THEN
SECONDLY- IN AND OF COURSE THE
REASON I ASK THAT IS THE DMV
HAS A HISTORY OF THE PASSIVE.
OF OVER CHARGING FEES HIGHER
THAN WHAT IS REQUIRED OF
PROVIDING THE SERVICE AND SO-
I'M I'M NOT SURE IF IT WAS YOUR
INTENT NOT TO PLACE A CAP ON
THE NEW FEES OR TO. SYSTEM
OUTPUT A CAP AND AT SOME POINT-
SO I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'D BE
WILLING TO DISCUSS ADDING
LANGUAGE THAT PROTECTS
CONSUMERS. WHO ARE NOT
PURCHASING THE DIGITAL LICENSE
PLATE- FROM THE ADDITIONAL FEES
AND JUST HAVING THE THOSE WHO
PURCHASED AT THE END OF THE DAY
THAT IS A LICENSE PLATE THEY'RE
THE ONES THAT WOULD PAY- BOARD
FOR. THE SERVICE. SURE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION- IT'S OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT. THE DMV
INTENDS TO CHARGE THE VENDOR
THAT ENTERS A PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE DEPARTMENT- WE DON'T
BELIEVE THAT THE DEPARTMENT
INTENDS TO CHARGE. CONSUMERS
VEHICLE OWNERS ADDITIONAL FEES
AND I'D BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH
THE COMMITTEE. AND THE
DEPARTMENT TO CLARIFY. THAT
THIS THIS INTACT. BUT AS- THAT
I THINK THE ONLY A QUESTION IS
THINK. IS I'M SUPPORT OF THE
DATA. OF SUPPORTING THE- I JUST
WANT TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC FROM
PAYING FEES THAT ARE HIGHER
THAN THE COST OF IMPLEMENTING
THE SERVICE IF THEY ARE
PARTICIPATING IN THE PROGRAM.
THANK YOU SURE THANK YOU.
MISTER GIBSON. THANK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND TO
THE- AUTHOR OF THE BILL I'VE I
DID THIS BILL LAST YEAR- AGAIN
THIS IS. PROMOTING TECHNOLOGY-
THIS IS A PILOT PROGRAM WE
MOVED TO- EXTEND THE SUNSET OF
THE BLM HAPPENS THE- THAT THE
MEMBERS MOVING THIS BILL
FORWARD THIS YEAR- I THINK
THAT- THE TECHNOLOGY ISN'T AS
OUT OF PLACE RIGHT NOW WITH
THIS BILL WOULD MASSIVELY MAKES
SENSE. THE DMV HAS HAD A NUMBER
OF PROGRAMS IN THIS SPACE. THAT
I THINK MAKES SENSE TRYING TO
WORK OUT ANY KIND OF- BOOKS IS
IN THE PROCESS- I THINK I'M A
CO AUTHOR F THE BILL AS WELL.
YEAH YES SO AGAIN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK AN AYE VOTE
BECAUSE I THINK THIS IS GOING
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION- IT HAS
RECEIVED A LOT OF SUPPORT- IN
THE YEARS THAT THIS BILL. BEEN
BROUGHT FOR TO EXPAND. ON THE
SUNSET FOR THE PILOT PROGRAM
THANK YOU. THANK. YOU ANY OTHER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- AB TO THANK
THE OFFER FOR WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND ACCEPTING THE
MOTION IS TO- PASSED WITH THE
AMENDMENTS- IS RIVAS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. HEY CAN WE HAVE A ROLL
CALL PLEASE. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO PRIVACY
CONSUMER PROTECTION COMMITTEE
FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I FONG.
FONG I BERMAN. BERMAN I
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM AYE DALY
DALY AYE DAVIES DAVIES I'D
GIPSON- GIPSON AYE KALRA. KALRA
KILEY THREE HI MEDINA MEDINA I
WAS VERY. WHEN. NO NOT LOADING
OKAY I'M SORRY- DONALD.
O'DONNELL ONLINE WARD WARD HI.
TEN TWELVE TWELVE ZERO TWELVE
ZERO THE BILL IS OUT- AND YOU
KNOW I THINK IT IS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFICULT FOR THE SECRETARY TO
HEAR BECAUSE OF THE MASKS IN
THE ROOM SO IF YOU'RE NOT
VOTING I THINK WOULD BE HELPFUL
TO SAY YOU'RE NOT VOTING- SO
THAT. THEY KNOW FOR SURE- SO
WITH THAT CAN WE GO BACK NOW
AND CALL THE ROLL AGAIN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. WHEN I ONE FINAL VOTE
NINE SIX I'M CERTAIN I'M SORRY
THE JUDGE. ALL RIGHT AND-
FOURTEEN FOURTEEN ZERO FROM
HERE. ON THE FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE AB NINE SEVENTEEN KERBAL.
ELEVEN ZERO WHEN. I CURRENT
VOTE TWELVE ZERO AND THEN FILE
ITEM TO EIGHTY ONE SEVENTEEN-
WHEN ON THE CURRENT VOTE ELEVEN
ZERO. WHEN UNLIKE THE ONCE. NOT
VOTING- OKAY ALL RIGHT ZERO AND
THEN WITH GO TO FILE A NUMBER
FIVE NINE EIGHTY FOUR YOU'RE
NOT VOTING ON THAT WINDOWS
ARIAN. OKAY OKAY THE CURRENT
VOTE IS. TEN ELEVEN TWELVE
TWELVE ZERO. FILE ITEM NUMBER.
SIX EIGHTY FIFTEEN ZERO THREE.
WHEN A KERBEROS TWELVE ZERO A
FIFTEEN YEAR FIXED SANTIAGO. AB
NUMBER SIX YES YES OKAY WHEN
YES SO THAT MAKES IT THIRTEEN
ZERO. AND THEN- FILE ITEM
TWELVE EIGHTY ELEVEN FORTY
SEVEN SO YOU'RE DEVOTED TO YOUR
HOME KERR VOTERS TEND TO PUT ME
ON I'M SORRY I APOLOGIZE THE
CARD VOTERS TEND TO THE NEW
YORK- FORTY SEVEN. YEAH THANK.
ALL RIGHT SO THAT MAKES OBSERVE
EXIT. THREE OKAY. THREE ALRIGHT
AND I THINK THAT'S IT. YEAH
THANK YOU ANNOUNCED THE FINAL
NOT OKAY. OKAY THANK YOU WITH
THAT LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS
BEFORE THE ASSEMBLY
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE IS NOW
COMPLETE WE ARE TURN.